yeah shut up Jim yeah not shut up Jim
yeah shut up June June June June June I
just wanna let you all know that I'm
truly sorry about everything
and after speaking to us dad my nan and
my family I've decided that I want to
tell you all the truth I can confirm
that the statement below is their truth
about husband ad saying that he was an
agnostic to us to me and his other wives
into believing that we were agnostics to
throughout some parts of our marriage
I'll be clarifying all the gratitude
miss Miller alhamdulillah I said I only
comb how're you guys doing here on the
detail shake cut any bubbles ate how you
doing brother how you doing how you been
I'm good laughs and we got to my right
here job are you doing how you been have
we made the connection here yeah yeah I
watch some of that debate where the wood
was nice except for me what a blonde I
mean so we're trying to derive obviously
there was a big some people call it an
infiltration some people call it you
know major hypocrisy hypocrisy within
a group that infiltrated the Muslims so
many different things being turned
around you're actually on the ground
you've spoken a lot about this we want
to kind of analyze it and and hopefully
derive some benefits so we can go ahead
and and and share some of the things
that can benefit the community not to
fall in the ground obviously you know so
capricious you know some people because
they were just joking around it was no
serious you know kind of what we're
doing but no really bad in terms of you
know going down the route those
individuals
well actually what we'll do and change
things right and there are lots of
accusations that we'll put forward but
at this stage no one has any solid
evidence however the situation started
to progress and withdraw and many
witnesses came forward many witnesses
Muslim witnesses with good character
that have no reason to lie about the
situation said that this individual has
actually apostate it from his lap one of
the individuals that was in their
relationship the man and that he
actually got his wife to apostate from
Islam as well she left Islam but when
they left Islam they will continue
we're in there you know still continue
to respond and continue their services
here which is reason for our people to
get the gym out and stuff like that and
and so what happened was you know there
was an account another account an
Instagram account which was which was
offered of this Sun woman basically and
there has been some woman that new
amount of laws or rules in the club and
this is the same woman you know that is
on this account I was the other account
I was going clubbing nightclubs with
other men and doing all kinds of things
so there was accusation so how could
that be that person so she's married but
with other men in pictures rappers and
famous people going through clubs and
these things so we can invert big fitna
and another layer specific knows the
fact that they collected three hundred
thousand sterling pounds for India and
three hundred thousand pounds which to
this day we don't know of the charity
because in English we have the Charities
Commission which is the over the same
body which travesties all the charities
and the jury Commission froze the money
them all the government they froze the
money three hundred thousand pounds now
we don't know which using Just Giving or
one of the fundraisers websites and we
don't know what charity they were going
to deliver that money with so the
government throws the money in the
account the issues there is that the
government actually this refund some of
the money of the people but some people
piss their cats with that money you know
because you know it's a cat all kind of
thing to pay and so they messed up
peoples are cats they miss they messed
up people's finances they took three
hundred thousand pounds which we don't
even know what
yeah and they were living double lives
so recently happened is we have
communications with with them and with
organizations that were working with
them now we are independent ourselves
we're kind of undertaking a journalistic
capacity and we spoke to those
individuals and we found that the best
way because the evidence was so heavy
that the girl herself wanted own terms
then have us show an exposure so what
happened was that she made the
confession in her home taps and she put
this online
so she confessed that they were living
double lives she confessed that he was
an atheist and that she was an atheist
at one point she confessed all of those
things now we're at the stage now where
the man himself has not made a
confession yet he's pretending that all
of this maybe is what the witness
testimony is there and what he doesn't
know is that we actually saw a video of
him making a confession but was filmed
he was you actually saw the video and
his wife confessed
both of them did and how he treated his
wives and what kind of relationship he
went into this not with the public
benefit is number one the idea of
idolizing public lewdness right and
people are instagramming things like
that so that because a lot of people
email buggers
number two in terms of giving a charity
in zakat to reputable sources number
three you have the most allows
individuals that come out on YouTube
just because there were certain clothes
you know that they pretend to be Muslim
sure and we also saw some of the text
messages between themselves and they
were saying they were very excited when
they converse people so they will now
are free they were trying to bring
people out of the slap and they were
happy to look like Muslims and do that
and
you know what basically one wife will
sing to another wife you know she Muslim
yeah yeah you know make her disbelieve
i'm a karakasa you know and then bring
out some different and at the end of it
you know the woman became an atheist a
third wife became an atheist so they
pushed her to become an atheist and so
on so forth
and that's at least what will
communicate in the in the message we saw
and so they were happy to see the
conversion of Muslims atheists and so
consulted effort to destroy Islam from
within and they were playing that game
wearing our clothes you know speak and
using using that in filtration tactic in
order to mislead people are one thing
that made me think about a lot was the
verses about all of those verses theory
windows of the house very dangerous or
puncture so that's pretty much a summary
of the events that's very tragic this is
like you can't make this stuff up this
is like you know yeah that's that's very
sad but that shows also the eveness of
of the Muslim community that you know
you know like they say it takes two to
tango you know you know you you got the
community ready to receive these guys
and compliment them and yeah it's it's
very sad very sad yeah yeah so we're che
where do we you hear you hear what's
going on now this is something that I
mean it surprises so many people out
there you know where do you go from here
how do you what benefits from what
you've heard what benefits can we derive
for first of all this is a phenomena in
the Muslim world it's a phenomena yeah I
just you know returned from Egypt
yesterday and you know I I happen to
just go through some of the TV channels
and you see that a lolly Monroe honey
this ritual scholar coming from this
country is coming to heal you one so it
is not something that is you know
exclusive to those individuals this is
actually something that is widespread in
the Muslim world and there are two
verses in surah al-baqarah one of them
actually it's called ayah to say the
verse
pertaining to witchcraft or sorcery
which is verse number 102 102 just read
the context of those two verses well
imagine a homeless woman in delay he
Musa Dagh Kali ma ma who and when a
messenger came from Allah to teach them
aspects of the unseen and how they deal
with it basically and and he is
confirming what came before it
they turned him down what Taba oh ma
tête Lucia le noir am will kill a man
they so instead of following the
revelation they went after the
witchcraft and the magic and and and all
that stuff the point I'm trying to make
is the main cause of this in the Muslim
world is ignorance not knowing you know
what those people are getting themselves
in to whether it is the individuals who
exercise the incantation the rakia or
the people who receive them well and you
know and and give them you know money
and pay them and all of that and and the
knowledge here which is there is a
drought in the Muslim world regarding
this knowledge the knowledge of the heat
because this subject it is very
interesting you know the subject of a
rakia and and and all of this there is a
very thin thread that takes you into Tao
hate and takes you into [ __ ] it's it's
you know they believe the moment that
you know FFF I go to Eddy and ask him to
do
rakia on me if I believe Eddie is the
one it's over that shirk
if I believe whatever Eddie says is what
we'll do it
what we'll cure is done its its history
and that takes a person who has
knowledge of the heat and also you know
the individuals who do this normally
they are after money
you know if listen of those people can
can do supernatural miraculous things
like speaking to the jinn and all of
this why why they are taking your $300
or $100 why why they are after your own
money so those people are after the
money and after the status you know and
that is why they end up you know selling
out everything that they have for
worldly gains yeah and and so forth how
do you how do you now look for someone
else because I heard is this correct
Mohammed ajob that the individual the
individual has a nap he actually did up
a video a livestream saying that he's
coming out now soon and just hold your
horses
is that correct so it was a very creepy
and
you know why's this thing he dozen of
the hereafter so you know it's a very
dangerous thing to be dealing with the
jinn and to be in that industry and
Allah some people saying that the reason
for his apostasy which she admit I don't
you he's miss to him by his apostasy at
one point well he came back what we
don't know what the reason why is
because he immersed himself in the
island of gin and these things and
linguist it was a very dangerous thing
for him to do and so Allah alum how he
came out but you know the way he kind of
presented himself in that live stream it
showed evil intent it showed lack of
remorse
it was creepy I mean he was laughing
smiling making jokes you know talking
about how famous he is showing off about
how many people are watching a live
stream it's not the how do we shake when
you hear all of this how do you receive
someone because we know lost want Allah
is the most merciful that someone comes
back and let's say there's a couple
possibilities-- someone comes back and
says look I made a mistake like you know
and and and now how do you receive
someone how do you deal with this from
here first let me even though Mohammed
brother Mohammed mentioned part of the
verse but let me just validate what he
said from the Sunnah there is an
authentic hadith aside Bihari that one
night the prophet sallallaahu Salam was
brain to head jute and there was a genie
actually who was trying to disturb his
serenity and Joshua presence of the
heart and mind and the Salah and he
actually caught the genie and he filled
the witness of the tongue in his hand
and he immediately you know let the
genie go on and released him and he said
has it been for the invocations and the
supplications of my brother Suleiman I
would have brought the genie tomorrow in
the morning and tied him to
one of the pillars of the Masjid and I
let the kids in madina and play with him
have have a good time with the genie so
the point here is what is the
supplication of brother of the Prophet
Sulayman alehissalaam prophet Sulaiman
me this application in a chapter called
heart were happily Malik Li and barrini
I had a mean body in a can tell you have
oh Allah bestow upon me a Dominion a
kingship power that no one else is
entitled after me and that power is the
jinn being subdued to that person to
Prophet Sulayman Ali Salim you see any
smart person who is in that field can
subdue dejenne to his service but you
need to understand the price he has to
pay is Islam stop hate he must
disbelieve in Allah in action and
actually the jinn would require that
person to come up with an act which is
really weird like taking the Quran into
the bathroom like staining the Quran
with blood and we read all of this so it
is possible for individuals I don't know
that individual has a net or whoever it
is exactly what he did but it is
possible for individual like for people
like those to get into that field of
sorcery and jinn and using the jinn but
the price they have to pay is they have
to disbelieve the jinn is not going to
serve someone without that compromise
the only one whom they serve they served
without this compromise was Prophet
Sulayman Ali Sarah because allah subhana
WA Ta'ala subdued the jinn to him so
this is clear because some people think
the only way that they can be saved is
through rocky so well let me just you
know mohamed i i i had a series in on
youtube called the world of jinns and
devils and and somehow is getting some
you know viewers out there and a lot of
the people they think because i spoke
about the subject then i'm a good rocky
so they call me from different parts of
the country and sometimes the world
actually asking me to do rakia on them
the first thing that I tell them you
know that request that you just made if
it is not in the right context you have
excluded yourself from the 17,000 they
could be more by the way who will enter
Jenna without reckoning without
punishment you know there is a famous
hadith hadith Anna's feel yeah the
prophet salaallah alayhi assalam says I
was made or eat Italian omen I was made
to see the nation's following their
messengers and prophets in their way to
Jenna beautiful hadith but I just want
to get to the point of reference here
then I saw a huge gathering so I don't
have them I said to gibreel this is my
Ummah he said no this those are the
followers of Moosa but now at the time
of Messiah and not the followers of
Moosa now only the people who followed
Moosa what Moosa was a prophet alayhi
Salaam then the Prophet SAW solemn said
to Gabriel ELISA Lam so to the Prophet
look here and look here and look here
this is your own ma this is your own
that there are more than that and with
them there are 70,000 who will enter
Jannah without punishment without
reckoning first the first basically the
first delegation of Muslims who will be
admitted into Jannah
Subhan Allah the prophet assalam got
called in I know that you know the
hadith Hagar but just for the sake of
the viewers to know what we're talking
about the
so the Prophet Solomon was called in and
and and then the Companions got so much
occupied who are those people because
they really wanted to be you know
amongst them and look at look at the
humility and the humbleness of that
generation that blessed generation they
excluded themselves they actually
started saying those are the people
probably who are born into Islam never
experienced shirk like us we came from
shirk into Islam so the professor Salaam
returned and he asked them what are you
discussing and they said we were trying
to figure out who are those seventy
thousand euros Allah who will enter
general without reckoning and without
punishment
he mentioned four things number one whom
will Lady Nellie Hester una well area
Tata Arun I will translate this well
ACTA 1y Elaraby metal : basically those
who have a hundred percent tower cool
reliance upon allah subhanaw taala now
sometimes seeking the rupiah
yes tarpon here if you actually analyze
this hadith we need physical Bihari
Aisha herself says that when the Prophet
would go to sleep he would read the
rockland himself he would result below
Allah WA had pulled out of rubble fella
pull out the bumpiness look at this now
and when he would get ill sick he would
ask me to recite the rakia on him so how
do you reconcile the two here you see
when you call that shake until shake you
do the rocky and right there then your
having already some sort of belief that
this person can benefit and harm it has
nothing to do anymore with allah subhana
wa that and that is why by the way read
that the story of the boy and the king
had it a survivor Rumi the story of
fulfill of dude what this boy you know
this boy who after he killed it that the
boy when he killed me the animal an and
and he started receiving this repetition
imagine like these guys who have this
YouTube and an Instagram like he said
her family knows I mean his name
circulated around the kingdom that this
guy cures that the first person who came
to him if you read the hadith carefully
was applying person who used to sit with
the king
he brought to him silver and gold and he
said to a Marinella kijima I brought all
of this for you in any chef I eat any
look at this now if you cues me if you
cure you cure me look at the boy this is
how it should be now this is how a Rakhi
should be first of all this Rakhi did
not spread his name around his name got
around I am against Araki who goes
around and and off and and and sure the
rakia online and unsure that is that is
your calling people to you you shouldn't
do this
people should contact you and now before
you even offer help to those people do
like this young man who did it listen I
cure nobody in nila ash viaje de well a
kin a la Hache fee allah has the one who
cures Eddy Allah is the one who cures
sin and tear mender be layer if you
believe in Allah right here sir elton LA
I will ask Allah I will invoke Allah
Subhan out that I will supplicate to
Allah to kill you and if Allah wills he
will cure you
you see that's that's that's that's the
culture the proper culture of rupiah but
to answer your question the ideal is to
recite Rakhi on yourself to recite rakia
on yourself I have a big issue with a
man going with a women inside the room
and reciting Rakhi on her so many times
this have been asked of me and said I
don't do the sister ask your husband to
do it you have a father
ask your father to do it yeah so all of
these things you know and and and money
getting into the process and and the
whole thing and fame
you know Instagram and viewers and and
all of this all of this makes it very
ambiguous and clear and and my advice my
advice always you know that you know
when you get that phone call can you do
a Rakhi oh you know the first question
that I ask this individual is what do
you pray five times a day normally the
answer is no ninety-nine point nine is
known my rakia is not gonna do anything
to you it's gonna help you for a half
hour and then you're gonna go back why
don't you start praying and then we'll
talk about the rock here you know so all
of these
you know if the person's interest is
really to help the community all all of
these elements and variables have to be
taken into consideration not just Rokia
and fame and money and all of this what
what are you guys now from from that
perspective coming from London what what
what is the community doing where the
person comes out from what you're saying
doesn't seem like the person's
remorseful regretful they're plotting to
put some kind of explanation together
how do you receive that when that comes
out there's gonna be a group now the the
followers there's people love the
suspense this drama right so it's like
Allah exposes something and now what's
the preparation when the people come out
receiving there's two ways you can go
the person is regretful the young made a
mistake you don't trust them again but
how do you that's the two point question
how do you receive them if they were
more so they're regretful and then the
other thing is if they come out now and
they're just like hey making this excuse
in that excuse how do you handle it from
both from there in London what are the
what are the scholars are they talking
about it what are they saying and what
do you what do you think what do you
guys just just for me to finish and then
Mohammed maybe I can take on from there
listen I don't know this person a quite
frankly and the only time I learned
about it when you you know send me that
information and you told me you're
coming to Chicago can we talk about this
I said you know I that's when I I
actually looked at the he referred to
the video of the sister who was crying
and de life and and and so forth
normally I tell you something when an
individual gets into that field and
there is much asset to lose and I'm
talking in general now I'm not even
talking about hasanat there is so much
to lose for this guy if if he is you
know it's gonna take a real man you know
toad because normally if if you commit a
sin and bublik if you inflict harm and
bublik you have to come and public and
do it you see that remorse and
repentance between you and allah only
applies to somebody who committed a sin
in a closed room without you know this
thing is famous now so he's gonna have
to come out and
if he wants to but now should we give
him the opportunity absolutely and I
think we should be you know soft you
know Letta Anil shaitana you come like
that the Prophet said to one of his
companions at one time do not help the
jinn he's already into the jinn you know
business of the jinn don't help the jinn
again is the guy I think we we need to
be a little bit maybe you know
compassionate in the sense of come on
man I mean your Acura is like brother
Mohammad mentioned one mile on Philly a
karate man held up your Acura is at
stake here
come on let's let's help you here with
you know what in I think we need to open
that and wait and see what will happen
your comments on it because you know
you'll need to make the issue is that
he's not even making repentance sorry I
was wrong these issues and so I think
the first room is his wife did that and
they believe he's making fun of everyone
and you know he's known for that which
is like that to come and apologize and
confess them you know make public
repentance and stuff like that and
there's so much oh well yeah I mean
because I think a lot of people
you know so the first the first point
that brother Mohammed made the
foundation for this famous hadith which
I'm certain you you you heard of it and
you know it both of you
but just for the sake of the viewers
hadith herbicidal Adri Salim Behari that
the prophet sallallaahu Salim sent a
delegation of companions to execute some
work and their way back they passed by a
tribe and it seems like the tribe the
tribe that the people of that tribe was
were very stingy they actually asked
them for food they refused to give them
food so the say little Heidi head of the
tribe the got stung by a scorpion and
they try to cure him with with all you
know types of cure that they are
familiar
with but at the end the man was about to
die so they said let's go to these Arabs
and and see if they can help us out so a
b-side throughout the 11 basically he
was the head of that delegation he said
we're not going to kill you I'm not
going to come and read the routier on
you unless you guys pay us something so
right here you're dealing with stingy
people who actually refused and you know
generosity is an Arab thing in at the
time and and that three days is
something that actually earth wise so
they refused to give them a little
killer or food you know - so you're
talking about people who are you know
stingy and a lot of the scholars said
those people were not Muslims a lot of
the scholars of hadith they said those
people were not Muslims so those are -
so basically you're asking a wage from
someone who is not a Muslim also the the
asking for the wage was contingent upon
the queue not just during the rakia so a
lot of us when we need that hadith we
have to be very careful because Torah -
Shiva you see every side went and he
recited l-fatiha on the individual vaca
and nama whole lemon occurred like a
camel who was tied and and you see how a
camel stands up that the guy just stood
up like nothing wrong with him so is the
cure a condition to receive the wage or
not this is something that is debatable
among the scholars but in general if you
go and do the rupiah you should not be
asking it you should be giving it as a
gift and you take it like they say
without it's the sharafat Neffs like you
know you're okay just like Allah here
and you go yeah that's how but it
shouldn't become a business it shouldn't
become a fee a wage you see that's where
you're stepping like I said there are
you see also if you if you read this
hadith carefully
I will say it you need to understand
this there is no such a thing rakia
Sharia in the sense of of served
things that you have to decide there is
no such a thing show me evidence what
there is no such a thing were known as
human and animal who was she fair Yuma
all of the Quran is Autopia all of the
Quran is a low key to understand
anything that you decide from the Quran
is all okay yeah
I acted though he'd I attack or say the
last two verses who Allah who idea they
have a lot of impact the names of Allah
they have a lot of impact but he see
when Abu Zeid went and sat next to this
leader of the tribe you know I would say
it believes that all of the Quran cures
so when he sat next to the person what
is the first thing that comes out of
spring out of your mind when you know
when you think of the Quran so he
respected l-fatiha
that is why when he went back to the
Prophet SAW Allah are you silent because
they refused by the way to accept the
wage they refuse to to do anything with
with what with the Jordan that the
brides they got until they go back to
the Prophet you know one of the first
thing that the Prophet said to a beside
one man you three can her appear how did
you know that l-fatiha is zero piya
so in a way that's the attitude of the
raka you recite the Quran and your
intention is Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
will cure so a shadow to answer the
question in brief here it is permissible
but I shouldn't make and and what if
somebody is unable to to to pay well you
you know refrain from helping the Muslim
and it shouldn't become a business it
shouldn't become of that nature
yes absolutely if somebody is unable to
recite the rakia on themselves yeah they
can go ahead and ask another person but
be careful when you ask another person
and it's really gonna take the other
person if the person doesn't know to
begin with how to recite the rakia you
think they know about the hate
do you know about who Allah is they know
what shirk is you know they they don't
know what the rasul allah i said i'm
said to medical a shy and less shy
ravana yarrow accompaniment her shirt
present you rakia to me what are you
reciting exactly so if the person
doesn't know how to recite the rakia on
themselves do you think they know now
hey now it's gonna take the rocky now
what is your issue okay do you believe
in Allah you see and and that is why
it's a condition for that rocky actually
to verify that person why are they
approaching me you think I have some
divinity about me here now or or what
what it is you see this is this is what
what led Muslims astray mean I would say
I would ear till battle and willful a
father one of the gates to miss guidance
that you start raising and I don't know
what's the word here you you're giving
the people you know this guy he does it
holy stream adulation yes
ideology you know me concerning somebody
into an idol yeah now it's gonna take
that person to stop this and I'll share
with you a story if you allow me asylum
a Muslim the prophet sallallaahu are you
seldom said anise is the narrator of the
hadith or by a shot of bore mad loot and
Mohini mad food and build up well maybe
somebody who is disheveled
you know dusted Dalton brain waiting to
old garments met Warren Billa Bob when
he knocks on the door of knock knock
knock open get out of here
who's this guy he's basically
insignificant yet but imagine this love
Oxana a la la Gila a burro but if he
takes an Ultron Allah Allah who will
fulfill his oath imagine oh Allah
I'm thinking and Otto knew that you give
Eddie you know Jenna yeah imagine Allah
who fulfilled that person's oath because
of his tears
imagine this that's a Kurama that's you
know the Prophet SAW solemn in this
hadith he named the brother half-brother
Ennis's name is alvaro I mean human
virile numeric but who were this hadith
handful of people not many people not
many people know about this about this
about al bara NSS have brother status
that he actually can take an oath on
Allah and Allah can fulfill his oath
few people top prophet saww Selim died
years passed by the Muslims were
invading a stronghold in Berea called to
stock and they were suffering a lot of
them were killed because that fortress
was really strong hold and and they
couldn't break through because it was
behind water and every day Muslims are
killed so some of the people came to the
leader of the sermon he said why are we
suffering we have this man in our army
if he makes Doha if he calls someone on
law the per I heard the Prophet saying
about him this about him we're going to
break through so the leader of the army
called upon the Barossa come here navara
why don't you make to her for us we see
us getting killed every day said no I'm
not gonna do it he refused to go again
then I'll borrow every day he would see
Muslims being killed then he finally
agreed I said okay I'm gonna do it look
that he need oh Allah
I'm taking an oath who knew that you
show us the back of our enemies tomorrow
and I die as a shade
I go why because the people of the army
now instead of relying upon Allah you're
gonna go to who it's too much now you
know that so individuals like those they
must have strong to hate the same exact
thing you know and he actually died when
you reach that status that you're able
to cure people like this your level of
the head has to what to grow right grow
up and be careful because you don't want
to become a turret who's at the hood
someone who is worshipped besides Allah
while he wants that one thing that you
know they take for example the same
exact scenario in the story of a way
Sultana
imagine the Prophet SAW Solomon if you
look at the credential of America
top-of-the-line
you know Holman was asked to check every
season of hydrogen and look for a man
coming from Yemen whose name is always
right in the middle of a story's
narrating regarding okay can you can you
share it with him quickly
go ahead well I was telling the story of
Wilbur ah of pneumatic you know again
like I go back to this principle you see
if you're dealing with somebody Mohammed
who doesn't know how to recite donkey
you know yes then it's gonna take you as
a Rakhi to draw the boundary to draw the
boundary because you don't want the
people to to basically to rely upon you
instead of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and I was sharing with with brother EDD
and the viewers the story of of awful
bra Abdul Malik one day the professor
Salim mentioned that if there is
somebody if he takes an oath on Allah
who's in significant significant looking
or by a shot alberto Lewton brainy
metaphor and bill up web now AXA Malala
Hillenburg and one of them is alberto
abdul malik the half-brother of Anna's
the Prophet died only handful of people
heard this hadith only handful of people
know this about el buro the Prophet
Sawa's Allen died years something like
that 24 after Hitler the Muslims were
trying to break into one of the
stronghold and Burgi and every day they
are getting killed for six months
they've been trying to go through so one
of the people came to the leader of the
army I said we have this man in our army
if he calls upon Allah if he takes an
oath on Allah Allah is gonna give us
what we want
why are we going through this the leader
of the army big dill borough he said no
I'm not going to do it after three days
he agreed look at his drama Hamid oh
Allah I am taking an oath who knew that
we see the back of our enemies too
meaning we chased them and I died as a
saint
I wanna die now now the word is gonna
get out that now instead of people
relying a button Allah that Alliance
upon who so that that's one of the major
things we can take from this one of the
main things is reliance on a lost want
out the created the heavens and earth
clear reliance on Allah there cannot be
any kind of an offense on this you see
the same exact thing we understand from
the story of how modern ways imagine
Omar was asked to look for someone from
Yemen who was not a companion Yoma if
you find this man ask him to ask Allah
to forgive you imagine this imagine
Allah is a companion if there is a
profit after that profit would be Omer
if Shaitaan Cesar Omar he will run away
from home are you understand this
Omar fine finally he finds the man finds
voice he finds him I said you know what
Weiss asked her he said what can I do
for you listen I'm going to her ah
please don't let anybody know about me I
wanna disappear you understand so well
they the scholars they differentiate
between Mara Jesus - Nabi Rasool what
Karamat already the merge is that the
miracle of a messenger a messenger must
disclose his met his miracle because
that what establishes that he receives
divine revelation but a person with a
status with a law that you can actually
kick out the jinn from somebody's body
this is the Kurama this is you have
connection with the unseen you gotta be
extremely careful extremely careful
hundred percent careful you cannot use
this for the dunya you cannot make it
into a business and you cannot be a
cause for people to go astray because of
you so they so they so this can be a
gift from Allah
yeah to the to the rocky but he's making
it clear this is not for me this is from
Allah he's got to make that really clear
i constellation with the boy in the
story of the trench let us go and it's
wide before we cut out a few more things
so what do you guys think about you know
people are bringing up this whole thing
about sharing sharing
your family on social media specifically
your wife or likes you know putting this
out this is by itself a criteria that
this person has no clue you know about
what do you understand the question and
then and then where I really have issues
because we used to have like in Jogja
Lea people back in Jogja Lea they like
to have the the trophy girlfriends right
so they'd have their girlfriends they
didn't have much feelings for him but
then they even that even the person back
in Jogja Lea then he start to get this
Leda this protective jealousy he's not
Muslim but but yeah every person every
human being has jealousy in him yes what
I can I'll carry my - moo-hoo well EEMA
you'll Giroux who but the person who has
taqwa and a man will hold it but the
person who has you know no taqwa no a
man no fear of allah will go after you
you see when you safari said i'm so that
dream huh about him becoming what did
the father say to them don't tell that
dream to who imagine you know we will
show ourselves in camera here allah
knows best who watches us and that's why
our shayateen and our general are very
big you know they are not small likewise
when you go and show your wife
especially now his wife's with with an S
at the end you know is oh man this guy
and you don't do that your kids you
don't do this
you don't know what's watching this you
understand the question now you can hear
us we're talking about yeah you don't
you don't do this as a Muslim repeat
you're breaking up
yeah oh just a little bitty woke up a
little bit I can hear I can hear you now
now you can hear repeated repeating yeah
hello yeah we were talking about you
were talking about putting your family
out there on display for likes yeah
absolutely and this was one of the
criticisms that was leveled against the
family even before any of this came up
because you know it seems a little bit
weird and and they invited the evil eye
and that's what the people were saying
to them even before this controversy spy
it and and some people nowadays have
this movement within you know the UK and
other places in the world where people
are denying the evil eye you know
they're denying the fact that Envy could
happen they're denying even divested
Jimny or Jew possession they're denied
it then they're denying the Quran and
Sunnah similarly yeah so they can live a
lot desires and so they can show their
families and and there's a problem as
well I believe that connected to social
media especially which is to do with the
fear of the man like a protective
jealousy like that become something
trivial now in liberal society where
people don't care the zero thing is
become outdated like you know he has
seen as against equality in fact
community perspective so a lot of people
have left this bit on our side they
don't mind even like you said any like
you know they like to show off their
their wives almost trophy like you know
in a trophy way you know this is my wife
she looks like and this subhanAllah
something which we don't talk about much
in in these discussions is the problem
of the aspect of the of the use of fear
this individual now loves always
protective jealousy and he allows us
like to do these things and this man
came have to be sorry to say he is their
youth because here is what I call coming
you know and that is an extreme version
of someone who is as their you
I mean I mean Roger compiled 14 tribes
or I think 14 or 13 if I'm not mistaken
allah subhanaw taala a to Leandre he
compiled all these a hadith that talks
about almost three three types of people
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala will not look at
at the day of judgement or speak to or
even give them any you notice kiya that
you know one of them is it the youth
that's how would you translate dies now
the youth is someone who sees wickedness
in your own family and you don't do
anything about it that one of the
families is the word see you seek a [ __ ]
but it's not the same exact as the you
know
you have no protective jealousy but it
doesn't have to do only with with the
the big thing fornication actually
whatever leads to that you know the way
that they dress the way that they speak
the way that they act and you see this
and you don't do anything about it you
don't put a stop to that of course that
the top of this is is that they go
wickedly around and and you're not doing
anything about it now not only this
you're contributing to this you're
making a show of your family you're you
know that that adds two two two two two
two
diantha that you yourself not only
allowing it in your small circle rather
you living it be out there in a social
media outlet or an Instagram or whatever
it is you know so so wrapping up now we
started off with trying to derive from
from from this this situation that
people many people traumatized by this
what what gems of wisdom can we derives
so we can go ahead and increase our iman
instead of many people losing some
people losing their Iman because it is
yeah actually this is knowledge the
issue has to do with knowledge knowledge
of tawheed you see the moment that you
believe that there is someone out there
who can benefit you without allies
permission can cause harm to come upon
you without Allah has permission forget
it your Tahiti's got ya your toe heat is
gone and that's why go and study the
heat especially the ego removing that
any harm any benefit allah subhana wa
ta'ala is the source of the not other
people you know if Allah permits harm to
come into you or upon you is for a
reason yeah you know is is for something
that you don't roam you go back and
study to hate the subject has to do with
the hate then and and the knowledge of
the hate unfortunately in the Muslim
Ummah there is a drought very few people
talk about it yeah yeah I'll mention a
couple things and then Mohammed you can
you can finish it off what comes to my
mind is that you know the learning
person is is how the Prophet SAW some
talked about is a thousand times heavier
on the shaitaan yeah so it goes back
with knowledge another thing the hadith
were the prophets awesome
talked about that you know a person will
do the deeds you know of the people of
Jena all the way to the end I'm
paraphrasing and then and then the
colour overtake him and then the person
pretty much be exposed can we relate
that to this situation that what's
perceived on the outside or someone
reciting Quran and everything it looks
good you know niqab but then they're
doing these deeds that you think they're
gonna get you to Jenna then all of a
sudden boom things get unfolded and
you're like wow this is like the
infiltration of Shaitaan at the highest
level and this makes me just increase
and like man this can happen to any of
it we have to be on vigilant in our pod
we have to be vigilant to make sure that
this is not a joke man this is like
shakedown is real this stuff is
happening man this is like you know you
got to take your Deen serious you cannot
miss a prayer be under will do take it
to the next level all the time make sure
you're protecting your family don't take
it as a joke you see this is real you
got people on the inside they can have
niqab they can have hijab all these
things but you if you don't have the
knowledge like you're saying reliance on
Allah you're gonna get taken for a ride
by a donkey by this key by that G you're
gonna be taking all over and you're
gonna end up in the club thinking you're
kicking it but you actually entered the
Hellfire the worst fitna that will occur
in the face of this earth what is the
worst fitna the DeJong yeah yeah imagine
some guy his creation is defective in in
the sense he has defect imagine one of
his eyes is done and he claims that he's
Allah and people are gonna believe him
soup animal community you can I read so
honey what are you closing up now
finishing off what what do you think we
could take away you know for that for
the you for people who are in these
people and now when he says that if
you're going to be someone so do so will
happen so every single person is alive
we're not
so you know you know on because you know
[Laughter]
you know so
being destroyed from being from be
corrupt thank you very much thank you
very much for joining us and on this
episode bringing us up to speed and
inshallah we can all take from this the
viewers and uh shall I implement these
things in our lives
hope to see you soon my brother how many
job I mean so I'll make room tomorrow
setup over again that's it closing up
che we got to go
yes we got to go Wow yeah thank you guys
for tuning in here to the Dean show take
that advice make sure reliance on allah
the creator of the heavens and earth get
to know your dean live your Dean and
know that shaitaan is for real and he's
always on the attack but make sure you
have reliance on your critter get to
know this Dean is so important don't
take it as a joke we'll see you next
time we'll see you here every week and
sha Allah God one until then peace be
with you
assalamo alaikum